-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-All right, here's our panel.
-He is a former foreign policy--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Oh, thank you.
Foreign policy advisor
to Senator Bernie Sanders,
who is now
the executive vice president
of the Center
for International Policy,
Matt Duss.
-Welcome to the show, Matt.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
And he's a columnist
for Tablet magazine
and author of Secret City,
The Hidden History
of Gay Washington.
James Kirchick
is back with us, Jamie.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Um... So, um, difficult week,
difficult to talk about it,
but we must.
Um, as often is the case,
this show is at variance
with some
of the conventional wisdom
and what we see
in the media a lot.
Um, mostly what I saw
this week was one,
a shocking amount of support,
like even at the moment...
(CHUCKLES) ...of the rampage,
or right after when they're
still counting the bodies.
That was shocking to me.
Uh, but even
at its best I feel--
feel like most of the people
who you would read in the media,
the attitude is sort of like,
"Well, you know,
this is very complicated.
I didn't really study it,
I don't really know the facts,
so I'm just gonna go with
a kind of
they're both guilty equally
and a moral equivalency,"
which I would like
to take issue with tonight.
I think the Israelis have always
had the moral high ground
and I think they still do.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-But, we'll get to that.
But, the...
I'd also like to say
to my friends in Israel,
there's a siege that's now been
going on for six days.
No food, no water,
no medicine is getting in.
The head of the Red Cross
in the Mid East said today,
"This is not acceptable.
We need a safe
humanitarian space."
I agree. (CLICKS TONGUE)
Uh, you know, don't lose
the moral high ground.
I mean,
I hate the word "proportionate"
when it comes to killing.
It's ho--
It's horrible, but it's sort of
like the best we can do.
JAMES KIRCHICK: What does
that mean, "proportionate"?
Well, I-- I just don't kn--
I don't know, but if Israel
is gonna kill babies now
for the next,
I don't know how long,
they're just gonna--
the world's just gonna
be able to say,
"You just do it
in a different way."
I'm just saying to Israel,
don't do what we did after 9/11.
Don't do a Vietnam.
Don't do an Afghanistan.
Of course, you should retaliate.
Of course, you have every right.
But this could go to a place
that is very bad for Israel.
I mean, I think your reference
to 9/11 is apt
because we're in a moment
right now of grief and trauma.
Um, Israelis, absolutely.
Um, and that's not a moment
to make great policy.
And I say that
with great respect.
Um, they clearly
have to respond.
They have every right
to respond.
The Israeli government
has every right
and responsibility
to defend its people.
What we saw, uh, last weekend
was absolutely shocking
and barbaric.
Um, there are no two sides
to that.
Um, we have to condemn
that unequivocally.
-There is no justification. I--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
I will say that--
That doesn't--
That does not mean
we can't have a conversation
about the deeper context here.
We have to have
that conversation.
That does not justify
in any way what happened.
You said there's a siege
on Gaza. That's right.
There has also been
a blockade, uh, since 2007.
Um, that is part
of this context.
Again, not a justification,
never a justification, um--
Well, a blockade from a land
they gave back.
-JAMES: Yeah.
-They gave back.
-Gaza is not occupied.
-MATT DUSS: Well, they withdrew
their forces and settlements
from within Gaza.
Okay, but the reason
there's a blockade
is to stop shit like this
from happening.
-No, I agree with that.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-That's the whole point.
-I think--
And--
They gave it back.
They said, "You know what?
Make your life your own."
This conflict right now
could end right this second
if Hamas were to put down
its weapons
and surrender unconditionally.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-I know, it would never happen.
But that's--
But that's the reality.
And this has always been the--
it's always been the reality
-of this conflict.
-BILL MAHER: Yes.
If the Arabs were
to put down their weapons--
And this goes back to the 1930s,
before the creation
of the state of Israel.
If the Arabs put down
their weapons,
there would be peace.
If the Jews put down
their weapons,
there'd be no more Jews
in the Middle East.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL: Yeah. Well, that's--
And that's the thing I wanna--
I wanna get.
I mentioned this, about...
Like, it bothers me,
the moral equivalency that
goes on in the American media.
I don't think Israelis would
ever purposely kill babies.
I think they have killed babies.
That's collateral damage,
which is another horrible thing,
but that's part of war.
-Well, purposefully or reckless?
-I think when--
I think that there's
a very big difference
between rejoicing...
-JAMES: Yes.
-...when you kill civilians,
and the Israelis' regret
-when they kill civilians.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
MATT: I'm not gonna take issue
with that, but let me add--
let me add one thing
about the context here.
Um, it is very important
to understand
that the Israeli strategy
up until last weekend
had been to bolster
Hamas' control of Gaza.
There was a report that came out
of Benjamin Netanyahu
talking to a meeting
of the Likud party in 2019...
-BILL: Yes.
-...saying, and I quote,
"Our strategy-- Anyone who wants
to prevent the creation...
-BILL: I saw that.
-...of a Palestinian state
has to bolster Hamas
and give them money.
This is how we keep
the Palestinians divided,
and therefore, there will never
be a Palestinian state."
This is not someone
who is interested in peace
with the Palestinians.
I'm sorry.
And this policy goes back
to the 1970s.
Well, that's coming after
75 years of being attacked.
Again, the question here is--
So, it's not coming
in a vacuum...
-I-- I totally agree.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-I would say there is--
-BILL: Let's-- Let's...
Again, part of the challenge
of talking about this issue--
And again, I just want to say
I appreciate being here
to talk about this and I--
You know, to have a really
respectful discussion here
'cause I'll just say it again,
what happened last weekend
is beyond shocking.
But I think we can disagree
about the history.
We can disagree
about who did what
and who's to blame
at different times.
But ultimately,
these two people are gonna
have to share this land,
and the question is,
how we get to that point?
BILL: Right.
And we will talk
about the history,
I just wanna finish
with the values first
because it's just amazing to me
that the American Left,
so much of it,
throws their lot in with people
whose values...
(SCOFFS) ...I hope
they don't share,
but let's go through them
'cause values and customs
make a difference, okay?
And the people of Gaza--
By the way, if the Israelis
did get rid of Hamas,
they'd be doing a giant favor
to the people of Gaza
who hate Hamas too.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But, uh, let's just go
through the lists.
Because the Israelis rep--
look like us
in most ways, values-wise.
Maybe we're not doing it
the right way. I don't know.
"Religious tolerance."
That doesn't exist in Gaza.
You're either Muslim
or an infidel,
and you'd better be a Muslim.
"Female freedom,
free and fair elections,
free speech, gay rights."
I see these
"Queers for Palestine."
JAMES: Did you hear
their sister organization,
"Blacks for the KKK"?
-(BILL LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
It's like...
By the way, I'm a gay man.
I've lived in Berlin.
This is a level of masochism
that even I cannot comprehend.
-Right. (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I mean...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
MATT: You know what?
I'm gonna just--
Uh, can I just finish my list?
Uh, "Pedophilia."
I'll put that under,
"Don't ask."
Child brides and so forth.
"Equality of the sexes,"
I'll categorize that under,
"Don't make me fucking laugh."
Qua-- Uh--
The fact that, you know,
these people think
that this is where they should
be aligned with,
that these are the values
that you support?
I think this past week has been
a real important moment
for moral reckoning
on the American Left
because there is a small,
and I'm gonna emphasize that,
a very small but growing
and extremely loud faction
on the American Left
that has revealed itself...
-BILL: I don't know how small
anymore.
-...to be--
Okay, well, I don't mean--
It was all over. It was--
Well, we just had a conversation
about the algorithm, right?
And I think you have
a few groups.
You have some college groups.
You have some activist groups.
BILL: It's college.
Okay. And again, I--
You know,
having gone to college,
I thank God every day
that social media didn't exist,
-uh, when I was there.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Um, but I will just say,
you know, my friend--
my friend, uh, Dan Drezner
from Tufts University wrote,
you know, I think recently, um,
he just posted it again.
He's like, "College is where
you go to say stupid things."
That is not
to defend what they said.
I think these things
were gross and reckless.
And I'll note that a number
of groups that have signed
some of these statements have
been pulling theirselves off it.
I don't want
to over-represent this
as part of the Political Left.
I absolutely accept
the responsibility,
as someone who is on the Left
and wants to build a responsible
and effective Left,
of calling this out.
Um, but I don't think
we should over-represent
these feelings on the Left
because they are not a majority.
They are not close
to a majority.
JAMES: I think we need to--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL: I hope not.
They're a lot bigger
than they used to be.
Well, we hear a lot more
about 'em because, as you heard,
there is an interest
in promoting this.
I think we need
to shut down Harvard University
until we figure out
what the hell's going on.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
You're s-- You're saying
they're not sending us--
they're not sending us
their best?
They're not sending us
their best, no.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-MATT: I do wanna say something
pretty serious here, though.
While I will maintain
and agree with James here
that this is a small minority,
um, I have heard
from colleagues,
Jewish colleagues on the Left,
and my friend Michelle Goldberg
wrote a piece
in The New York Times.
My friend Josh Leifer
wrote a piece in Dissent.
And I've been struck
by personal conversations
here too from Jewish colleagues,
on the Left
who I consider allies,
very close friends,
and they have been shocked.
And I take that
very, very seriously.
Because, again, as someone
who wants to build a serious
and effective Left,
if Jews do not feel that
the Left is a home for them,
we will not have a serious
and effective Left.